bonjour Alexis Corbière merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
député la France insoumise de la scène
saint on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représenté par
Fabrice Vesson du groupebra les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France bonjour
Fabrice bonjour orien bonjour Alexis
Corbier bonjour on va évidemment parler
de plusieurs sujets d'actualité du
conflit au ProcheOrient mais on commence
par aras vous êtes prof vous Alexis
Corbier prof d'histoire Go comme
l'étaité Samuel pati assassiné il y a 3
ans jour pour jour comme l'étit la cible
initiale du tueur d'aras c'est un
professeur de français qui a été visé
Dominique Bernard tu es nouvelle victime
du terrorisme islamiste à 14h une minute
de silence sera respecté Gabriel Atal
hier soir au 20h a dit qu'il ne toléra
aucune contestation aucune provocation
durant cette minute de silence et
qu'elles seront sanctionnées si elles
ont lieu il a eu raison de se montrer si
ferme bah il va soit que si on fait un
moment de recueillement de dignité faut
être vigilant à ce que ce soit pas une
caisse de résonnance à des propos qui
seraient insupportable moi je
voudrais dire une chose vous et merci de
l'avoir pointé je suis député depuis
2017 mais mon métier c'est professeur
d'histoire en lycée professionnel et
hier j'ai tenu à aller à
aras sur cette place des Héros
participer à cet hommage extrramement
poignant sur cette place qui est très
belle une place Royale carré dans cette
ville magnifique énormément
d'émotion j'ai vu discuter avec beaucoup
de personnes des des professeurs déjà S
que on va parler de l'aspect le plus
sombre de l'âme humaine ce crime
terroriste islamiste mais d'abord
insister sur ce qu'il a eu de plus
inspirant de lumineux le courage de
Monsieur Bernard qui s'est sacrifié
pour défendre ses
élèves parce que manifestement ça a été
pointé le criminel voulait frapper un
professeur d'histoire et Monsieur
Bernard la presse l'a raconé s'est
interposé mais d'abord je veux dire on
était place des héros c'est un de nos
héros ce que je veux dire c'est que dans
C moment on pourrait peut-être
désespérer il faut se dire que ce
professeur de sport ce cuisinier cet
autre personnel de l'éducation nationale
qui sont physiquement interposés devant
un homme avec un couteau nous montre
qu'il y a aussi dans l'humanité des
choses extraordinaires des gens qui sont
prêts tout simplement selon la l'idée
qui se font de leur métier à risquer
leur vie deuxièmement l'école l'école
c'est beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui parle
de la République
c'est la base de la République le socle
il faut la défendre mais là encore ce
que j'ai senti hier parce que je vais
vous dire il y avait une grande émotion
puis après comme les gens m'ont reconnu
on parle il y a une colère y compris de
gens plusieurs des gens qui mais même
des gens qui sont proches de nos idées
ou et qui ont le sentiment maintenant
que il faut
agir notamment c'est bien comm ministre
apporte son soutien à Monsieur ATT est
un politique qui s'est trouvé des mots
mais les gens ont l'impression que ça
fait des années qu'ils sont abandonnés
quand il ce ne sont que des mots ce que
dit Gabriel hatal vous pensez qu'il ce
ne sera pas suivi moi bon il y a des
sujets mais je l'ai déjà pointé monsieur
hatal ministre de l'éducation nationale
ne doit pas oublier monsieur hatal
ancien ministre du Budget quiil y a
quelques temps lorsque nous parlions du
budget de l'Éducation nationale que nous
lui réclamions notamment qu'il a des
moyens supplémentaires qui soient donnés
nous les refuser moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une visionférence avec le
ministre samedi bon il a des mots forts
qu' ne lesignera pas dans les moyens
qu'il faut donner mais quand nous avions
le
débat budgétaire il nous l' refusé je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il va y avoir des
493 qui vont être utilisés sur les
prochains budgets donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que les gens c'est pas le cas
c'est un budget en haut c'est le budget
de l'Éducation nationale mais ce n'est
pas vrai par exemple alors qu'il y a une
augmentation d'élèves dans le second
degré nous en sommes à moins
d'enseignants à l'heure actuelle que ce
qu'il y avait précédemment il y a un
nombre significatif d'enseignants je le
perd avec les l'émotion je crois qu'il y
a près de 8000 postes d'enseignants en
moins dans le second degré pour bon donc
pour une augmentation de 21 il aussi des
postes non pourvu alors mé plus voilà
pour quelle raison aujourd'hui moi quand
j'ai passé le concours d'ancien en 1995
il y avait beaucoup de gens et ceux qui
avaient la la chance de réussir c'était
pas simple aujourd'hui il y a même des
postes qui sont non pourvus pourquoi on
ne veut plus enfin on ne veut plus façon
de parler pourquoi ce métier s'est
autant dégradé deuxièmement dans
beaucoup d'établissements plus de
médecins scolaire plus de psy col
scolaire plus d'assistant Scola on me
dira on est loin du drame qui a eu lieu
mais on sait qu'il y a des élèves
certains ne vont pas jusqu'au crime mais
qui mais qui sont dans une situation que
que nous ne prenons pas assez en charge
et et pour terminer pardon parce que moi
j'ai parlé avec un professeur qui avait
eu l'élève criminel en 3e ça fait des
années que cet élève a été repéré
signalé il avait des propos en courts
très clairement garçon intelligent
manifestement engagé
refusant quand le professeur parlait de
laïcité s'enprenant il m'avait raconté
le détail quand il s'agissait de
l'Empire romain en fait non tout était
sujet à controverse et il y a pas
controverse très violente et propos trè
très très violent et ce que vous disait
le professeur hier c'est on a signalé
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe après nous
comme enseignant on sait pas est-ce que
le chef d'établissement était au courant
que était fichess qu'est-ce qui se passe
beaucoup de questions sont posé estce
que ça veut dire qu'il n'aurait plus dû
se trouver sur le territoire français
alors après il y a une autre discussion
qui est posée qui est que moi je
considère là aussi il faut sortir des
contr il va so que quelqu'un qui est
dangereux il faut créer les conditions
et qui n'est pas français peut être
expulsé maintenant attention là à droit
constant par que je vois bien la
disction qui est en train de venir à
droit constant des mesures pouvaient
être prises ça ce n'est pas vrai qu' a
besoin de changer la législation pour
éventuellement le père d'ailleurs avait
été expulsé et le jeune homme qui depuis
est devenu un adulte pouvait l'être
éventuellement donc pour vous il y a une
faille il aurait dû être expusé alors le
sujet voilà le sujet est plutôt moi
c'est au professionnel de le dire
maintenant qu'est-ce de quoi on
s'aperçoit ce que nous dis les est votre
avis est-ce qu'il aurait dû être expuléz
mon avis c'est que s'il faut l'expulser
qu'il le soit ce que je dis par contre
c'est que quand on voit que les
spécialistes nous disent que la DGSI
aujourd'hui c'est 5000 personnes que
pour suivre avec un peu plus de qualité
il faudrait 8000 personnes là c'est un
sujet sujet Quelle est la qualité de
notre renseignement parce que c'est pas
à vous et à moi de décider la
dangerosité de telle et telle personne
et il faut sortir du débat que toute
personne frappée de qtf doit être
expulser parce que c'est absurde parce
qu'on met sur un pied d'égalité une
maman je pense à quelqu'un que je
connais très bien dans ma
circonscription qui les femmes de ménage
qui travaillent et qui elle est là est
parfaitement je trouve c'est injuste
parce qu'elle est là depuis des années
qu'en vérité après avoir eu des carte de
séjour et cetera et puis quelqu'un qui
est manifestement dangereux donc il faut
qu'on puisse cibler parler de choses
sérieuses pas faire des effets comment
dirais-je de grande généralité qui nous
désarme donc je le dis le débat qui est
devant nous selon moi est un débat plus
de renseignement qu'un débat
d'immigration et c'est la même
discussion que j'avais avec Monsieur
daranin à l'occasion de la loi
séparatisme on a c'est c'est peut-être
un peu lié aussi Alexis Corbier ce matin
Emmanuel Macron demande au préfet de
réévaluer les fichiers des personnes
inscrites radicalisé expulsable Gérald
armman un samedi il dit il faut expulser
tous les fichiers s étrangers suspectés
de radicalisation est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ne le faisait pas
précédemment puisque ça lu paraî comme
une évidence aujourd'hui je me méfie des
effets d'annonce qui consiste à dire
pour quelle raison il découvre des
choses qui exprimai comme ça semble des
évidences c'est qu'est-ce qu'il est en
train de nous dire que tous les gens
dangereux soit que l'on protège les
Français oui cela va monsieur le
ministre mais pourquoi n'avez pas vous
fait navez-vous pas fait précédemment
parce que peutê parce que peut-être que
précisément notre renseignement en
raison des politiques publiques qui sont
mené n'a pas les moyens combien de gens
qui le sujet Faros c'est quoi Faros
c'est un peu le même débat renseignement
qui qui c'est qui qui qui surveille sur
les réseaux sociaux éventu la platene de
signalement du ministère de l'Intérieur
chargé de surveiller les messages sur
les réseaux avant le drame Samuel Patti
30 personnes seulement pour suivre des
centaines de milliers de messages depuis
le drame Samuel Patti 50 20 de plus
c'est insuffisant donc je ne voudrais
pas que et je vois bien le débat qui
vient on va parler politique
d'immigration et bien souvent cela n'a
rien à voir si ce'est politiquement
d'agiter des choses parce que vous avez
des gens qui menacent le territoire
national et qui menacent pardon les
Français qui sont des Français qui sont
est en France donc le problème est
d'abord le renseignement nous sommes
face effectivement à des menaces
indiscutablement qui méritent que l'on
voit dans le détail de quoi il s'agit
que l'on détecte les choses et là le
ministre luiême vousz pas répondu
clairement est-ce que si le
renseignement détecte il faut expulser
et je vous l'ai dit si des gens sont
dangereux il faut les expulser ça c'est
pas le sujet ou alors il faut les mettre
en prison les contrôler il faut agir je
veux dire personne va vous dire NON NON
quelqu'un est dangereux faut rien faire
non non attention ça serve pas de
prétexte à ce que il y ait des gens qui
fassent uniquement un grand débat
politique qui font du bruit mais ne
donne pas les moyens à nos services de
renseignement je dis bien nos services
de renseignement de savoir qu' la nature
bien compris alexbi pour vous c'est
d'abord un problème de renseignement
avant d'être un problème d'immigration
euh je m'adresse à l'enseignant
euh on a première question d'abord on a
l'impression que vous vous êtes mis à la
place de Dominique Bernard un moment
écoutez quand quelqu'un vous dit euh moi
ce que j'ai ressenti hier que vous êtes
professeur d'histoire que quelque part
l'assaillant alors je crois est-ce qu'il
se met à par vous savez ce que c'est
d'être face à une classe voir une bien
sûag j'imagine que quand on est
professeur évidemment et il ne faut
surtout pas que ce soit le cas mais
quand vous avez un sentiment qu'il y a
une tension qui n'est avec un élève
comment reprocher à nos professeurs de
se dire regardez qui est arrivé à
monsieur paattis qui est arrivé à
Monsieur Bernard et pour autant c'est
facile à dire sur un plateau il faut
rester debout cela a été dit et l'école
ne doit rien lâcher il est hors de
question que quiconque est comm
fanatique dicte à l'éducation nationale
et à la République qu'elle doit
enseigner à nos élèves parce que moi je
continue à penser comme Victor Hugo que
chaque fois qu'on ouvre une école on
ferme une prison et dans certain point
une prison une prison obscurantiste donc
c'est l'enjeu mais je reconnais qu'il y
a de quoi être inquié justement le
profil de l'assillant là fait état d'une
radicalisation familiale grandissante
bien sûr un jeune qui frappe sa mère à
la demande de son P inacceptable hein
son frère en prison pour tentative
d'attentat pardon et des enseignants un
enseignant assassiné et des centaines
d'autres qui se résigne à ne plus
enseigner la choix monsieur le
professeur d'histoire est-ce que ce
n'est pas là le terreau un terreau le
terreau le plus favorable à votre
adversa rassemblement national al on
enseigne la Choa vous savez ça c'est ne
faisons pas croire des choses qui ne
sont pas exactes on enseigne la Choa
aujourd'hui on montre les documentaires
sur la Cho vous savez qu'il y a des
enseignants des professeurs d'histoire
qui ont peur d'enseigner la chois
aujourd'hui vous savez ça mais mais qui
l'enseigne quand même globalement ça je
je ne laiss pas globement vous l'avez
dit oui non mais qui font qui qui qui
l'enseigne là-dessus franchement ne
faisons pas croire queon enseigne plus
dans lesétablissements scolaires mais
revenons à l'essentiel vouslud vous élud
un point c'est c'est un ça constitue un
danger pour un certain nombre de
professeurs d'histoire d'enseigner la
Choa dans certains établissements
scolaires d'où vous tirez cet élément
mais vous le savez comme moi non alors
ça entre vous et moi sortons de ce de
discussion vous le savez comme moi ça ne
signifie rien moi je connais des
professeurs d'histoire tout ce que je
connais continuent à enseigner la Choa
d'accord par contre que tel que je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure et avant que
posie la question je vous le dis que des
professeurs et des professeurs
d'histoire et en quelque sorte une
certaine émotion qui a peut les amener
dans le cadre de leur métier à se poser
des questions ça c'est une évidence
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on forme on
aide on accompagne d'accord on donne les
moyens c'est ce que m'ont dit hier les
les enseignants mais bon sang est-ce que
on peut nous former on nous dit il faut
la laïcité aujourd'hui c'était des
mesures qui avaient été prises par
Monsieur Blanquer dans le casadre de
l'éducation civique bon aujourd'hui
c'est quoi c'est une demi-heure par
semaine dans le cadre de
l'histoire-géographie c'est quasiment
rien c'est du baratin quelle est la
formation véritablement des enseignants
puisqu'on parle laïcité sur cette
laïcité quasiment rien également les
professeurs en non ralb dernièrement
sujet très important à l'occasion du
harcèlement scolaire le ministre a dit
on va faire des cours d'empathie
pourquoi pas mais ou quoi comment dans
quelles conditions est-ce qu'on paye nos
enseignants est-ce qu'on donne des
moyens à ce que ce métier soit plus
attractif est-ce qu'on remplace L qu'un
professeur est absent est-ce qu'on
l'accompagne véritablement sur une
formation spécifique et précise pas des
grandes généralités parce que quand vous
avez ce type d'élèves dont nous parlons
c'est pas c'est pas simple on n'a pas
été formé pour ça donc voyez il y a
beaucoup de paroles qui suivent des
grandes moment d'émotion de la part de
ministre qui lorsqu'ils sont ministres
du Budget disent ah non faut pas plus de
moyens parce qu'il faut faire des
économies et qui après disent il faut
accompagner les élèves on a compris
Alexis corb un dernier mot là-dessus
puisque on l'a dit il y a se pose la
question de la politique migr il y a le
projet de loi immigration qui sera
examiné au Sénat le 6 novembre est-ce
que vous souhaitez qu'il soit inscrit
rapidement à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée non pas enfin il faut qu'il
doit être débattu mais je je pense que
d'ors et là de ce que je vois venir
c'est que c'est le 1è texte qui se suit
depuis des années chaque fois le
ministre vient en BB le torant cette
fois-ci on va régler le problème
d'accord on considère que bien souvent
parce que là on est sous le coup de
l'émotion et je faut quand même pas
raconter à nos concitoyens que les
immigrés sont responsables des crimes et
des attentats qui sont commis sur le
territoiretion non mais Géral il dit
qu'il aurait là aujourd'hui il est non
expulsable et qu'avec son texte il
aurait pu être expulsé je crois qu'il a
tort il a tort à droit constant il
pouvait faire des choses s'il ne le fait
pas c'est parce que son propre service
public bien souvent du renseignement et
de la police est affaibli moi vous savez
je défends la police concrètement
c'est-àdire qu'elle ait des moyens de
travailler et pas qu'elle soit l'objet
la police d'instrumentalisation yelbrun
pivé veut une adoption avant la fin de
l'année est-ce que vous aussi pure
instrumentalisation pour montrer regardz
on agit alors qu'on m'a fait le coup sur
la loi séparatisme j'ai en souvenir là
débat sur la loi séparatisme je le
disais à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale vous ne donnez aucun moyen
pour le renseignement vous ne donnez
aucun moyen pour l'école alors que
c'était censé être un texte en réaction
à au crime odieux qu'avait subi Samuel
paatti donc les Français écoutez-moi
qu'on ne vous fasse pas le coup à
l'occasion d'un DRAM de textes qui
passent à côté du sujet qui sont des
textes d'agitation pour faire croire
donc vous voulez pas vous voulez pas
qu'il soit inscrit rapidement à
l'Assemblée il doit être débattu mais
pas avant la fin de l'année pour vous
c'est pas un objectif ben je veux dire
c'est l'objectif de gr écoutez ce texte
ne donnera pas de moyens supplémentaires
pour régler les problèmes auquels nous
devons faire face on va parler d'Israël
Fabrice
oui est-ce que vous pensez que la France
insoumise a suffisamment condamné les
actes du Hamas est-ce que les mot étaent
assez fort la France insoumise là aussi
a condamné les actes du R qu'on n
vienent pas à dire tout et n'importe
quoi au nom de polémique
politicienne questionétait suffisamment
condamné moi je l'ai condamné
immédiatement certains de mes amis il
l'ont fait immédiatement mais pas tous
vous le savez Alex cor est-ce que vous
vous qualifiez le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste oui c'est une organisation
qui soutient des actes terroristes donc
c'est une organisation terroriste après
que quel est le
débat le débat est le suivant nous avons
tous été indigné par et le mot est
faible ce qui s'est passé en Israël
l'attaque le crime odieux de population
civile de villages massacrés images du
kibut de la fête de ces jeunes filles au
cours d'une rêve partie assassinée et
cetera l'horreur l'horreur absolue
condamnation
évidente mais c'est un conflit qui dure
depuis des années il faut trouver la
paix il faut frapper sans aucun doute
les coupables mais la la réaction qui a
lieu de la part du gouvernement
israélien d'un gouvernement extrêmement
critiqué en Israël de la part de
netaniaahou extrêmement critiqué par la
société civile israélienne qui considère
que netaniaahou porte une responsabilité
par l'absence de protection notamment de
la frontière à Gaza sans doute en
faisant monter des troupes en sjordanie
et puis enétant bon incapable de faire
face à une situation où il n'a que
brutalité il n'avance pas vers un
processus de règlement politique et
aujourd'hui surtout des bombardements de
la population à Gaza 2,5 millions de
personnes qui sont des civils et des
innocents qui ne va faire rentrer la
situation que dans une trappe sanglante
qui va encore plus envenimer les choses
le droit à la justice ça n'est pas le
droit à la vengeance donc que les choses
soient claires et certains pensent que
si on
qualifiait uniquement du mot terroriste
on ne pourrait pas par la suite
considérer comme cri de guerre les
éventuelles frappes contre les
populations civiles à Gaza moi je pense
qu'on peut faire les deux vous me suivez
on peut condamner le terrorisme vouloir
que les terroristes soient traduits
parce qu'ils ont commis des crimes de
guerre dev évent la Cour pénale
internationale qui des sanctions qui soi
posées n'entraîne pas pour autant que
l'on puisse pas aussi dire que ce qui
vise à créer de Gaza aujourd'hui une
situation où les hôpitaux peuvent même
plus soigner il y a plus d'eau plus
d'électricité on dit à 1 million et demi
de personnes dès demain ou dans 48 he fa
partir est le Hamas est une organisation
terroriste mathil pan ne l'a pas dit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne l'a pas dit est-ce
que c'est une faute politique vous vous
en jugerez moi je pense qu'il fallait
moi je pense qu'il faut parler
clairement voilà il faut que les choses
les gens comprennent pour quelle raison
je vais vous dire parce que moi je pense
que dans la période une organisation
politique comme la mienne moi je suis
pas diplomate faudra qu'il y a des gens
qui qui parlent qu' a des solutions qui
soi trouvé je fais de la politique je
veux que les Français comprennent mais
je pense que pour parler clairement il
vaut mieux le dire c'est ce que le débat
Inter que nous av avoir c'est ça nous
affaiblit ça affaibl peut-être un peu
notre parole pour dire quoi aux Français
que nous condamnons de manière la plus
ferme les attentats qui ont eu lieu mais
aussi la France doit dire clairement par
l'intermédi de sa diplomatie madame
Colona est est là-bas au gouvernement de
netaniaahou folie que de bombarder les
populations à Gaza les crimes de guerre
qui vont il y a 2200 personnes à Gaza
dont 734 enfants qui sont morts
dernièrement des frappes israéliennes
Emmanuel Macron le premier appel à
préserver les populations civiles c'est
ce qu'il a dit je il a dit il faut
préserver les population civ
bombardement sur ce qu'est la ville la
bande de Gaza nécessairement va avoir
des conséquences terribles et je
regrette que le Président de la
République qui a pris la parole je sais
plus comment jeudi n'est pas dit cesser
le feu tel que nous l'avons toujours dit
il a donc c'est pas clair et Madame
colon il a pas dit cesser le feu mais il
a appelé à une réponse juste il a dit
qu'il fallait préserver les population
personne de sérieux ne peut croire il a
rappelé la positionition de la France
qu' fallait de état madame oui ça c'est
très bien très bien il faut avancer
là-dessus paix et personne de sérieux ne
peut croire que quand vous bombardez tel
que que le fait actuellement l'armée
israélienne est telle qu'elle avait déjà
commencé à le faire jeudi il n'y aura
pas des dégâts collatéraux donc ensuite
dernière chose moi je pense aux otages
et en plus il y a des otages français je
veux dire c'est qui peut croire que
c'est en faisant ce genre de frappe que
l'on va protéger les otages il faut
qu'il soi libérés au plus vite faut agir
donc là encore crime de guerre
indiscutablement de la part du ramas
situation intolérable et aussi crime de
guerre manifestement de la part de
l'armée israélienne il faut sortir de
cette situation vous préféreriez que la
France ne prenne pas part à ce à ce
débat et à ce conflit mais elle doit
prendre part en disant paix et cesser le
feu et moi ce dont je rêve c'est qu'en
France même une grande manifestation
pour la paix soit faite dans lequel se
retrouvent tous les Français quelle que
soit j'ai envie dire leur conviction
spirituelle quelle que soit la manière
dont ils abordent ce conflit mais étant
convaincu d'une chose Israël a droit à
la
sécurité et il faut au processus
politique qui respecte notamment les
accord de l'ONU pour que les
Palestiniens aussi aient droit à un état
deux états c'est c'est le moment que les
diplomates parlent il faut des militants
de la paix et trop de gens violents
s'expriment dans cette situation c'est
ça que nous avons porté me semble-t-il
et si c'est moi je le fais avec mes mots
me semble-il de manière claire un mot
puisque vous dites que ça affaibli la
France insoumise la la position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce que le groupe
parlementaire pourrait se scinder est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une fracture au sein de
la France ins est-ce que vous vous
pourriez créer un autre groupe avec
clémentinant avec François ru je suis un
homme d'unité de rassemblement je dis ça
je dis il le faut mais l'art de la
politique c'est rassembler des des gens
qui par définition parce que la
complexité du monde amène à ce qu'on
peut avoir différentes manières des mots
des stratégies différentes à se
rassembler pour être plus fort je le dis
pour la France insoumise moi je suis un
fondateur de la France insoumise mais
enfin de quoi vous me parlez c'est
incroyable je n'ai pas quitté quoi que
ce soit vous n'avez pas eu envie de
quitter le mouvement de prendre des
absolument pas absolument pas au
contraire je est-ce que vous demandez à
Manuel bonp par un vote en interne pour
savoir quelle est la position la faire
de quelle manière franchement ça
intéresse pas ceux qui nous regardent la
manière je mène la discussion en interne
vous me parlez mais non mais c'est c'est
pas vrai pour vous il doit pas y avoir
de discussion en interne de V en interne
je les porte je les porte c'est de
notoriété publique mais avouez que je je
vous connais et vous n'êtes pas
complètement vous ne mangez pas
complètement de ce planl mais certains
médias avec gourmandise veulent
absolument exacerber les désaccords
caricature y compris la position de de
certains en faisant croire que la France
insommie serait devenu l'ami des
terroristes en faisant croire je ne sais
trop qu quelle sautise c'est absurde et
ça n'aide aucune discussion à l'inverse
nous avons des débat pour ma part je les
ai posé il y a plus d'un an c'est
notoriété publique je me suis reconnu
aussi dans la parole de François Ruff
dernièrement de celle de clémentinetin
c'est une notoriété publique mais je il
y a un point un point de divergence
majeur sur la laïcité vous avez un point
de rupture sur la laïcité notamment avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous avez vous le
savez il est aussi fondateur de la
France sou vous êtes amis non mais vous
dites un point de rupture la laïcité il
faudrait faire une heure de discussion
de quoi on parle c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui m'a appris ce qui était la
laïcité je suis un défenseur la laïcité
loi de 1905 loi 2004 d' étance scolaire
je les défends mais pas
d'instrumentalisation auourdui est
est-ce qu'il la défend comme vous le
voudriez comme vous il vous l'a appris
citez-moi un point précis pour savoir de
quoi on parle moi je ne veux pase sur la
rupture non mais vous vous défendez
l'unité vous défendez l'unité au sein de
la franceise on a compris mais voilà non
mais je va venir à l'unité de laanupess
vous avez Olivier fort qui dit il y a un
problème avec la méthode Mélenchon
demain il y a un conseil national Ops
pour décider si assion ou pas Fabien
Roussel qui dit là c'est pas une
différence c'est une rupture
fondamentale marine Tondelier qui dit la
même chose est-ce que l'anupe
aujourd'hui est fracturé est-ce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fracturé l'ANUP
alors comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
toute proportion gardée qu'il faut des
militants de la paix quand il y a un
conflit il faut des militants de l'unité
quand il y a une situation de tension et
nous travers écoutez-moi nous traversons
une situation de tension donc il y a des
gens certains qui disent on peut plus
continuer comme ça il y a des gens comme
moi qui disent faut trouver les
conditions qu'on continue comme
ça alors c'est quoi pour quelle raison
je plaide pour que ce soit encore
possible c'est pas pour le bonheur de se
réunir avec je ne sais trop qui c'est
que je pense que c'est indispensable
pour gagner en 2027 je ne veux qu'une
une chose qu'en 2027 nous puissions
l'emporter parce que ma ma lecture des
événements c'est qu'il est possible que
l'extrême droite l'emporte il est
possible que nous nous retrouvions dans
une situation de grandension vos
partenaires ils disent pas on veut pas
d'union ils disent on veut pas d'union
avec Jean-Luc méchon on veut une autre
union de la
gauche jeis faire une déclaration
extrêmement puissante si on veut l'Union
des forces populaires de la gauche et
les écologistes il faut le faire avec
les forces populaires la gauche et les
écologistes ce que je veux dire c'est
que
jeve mais avec la France insoumise et je
me et avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est
aujourd'hui qui a un statut particulier
la France insoumise qui a été candidat
qui nous dit qu'il souhaite être
remplacé qui nous dit faites mieux
faisons mieux faire mieux c'est pas
faire pareil voilà ce que je dis alors
c'est on a le droit comme tout le monde
de critiquer Jean-Luc monchon on peut
aussi critiquer les autres hein parce
que Fabien Roussel que j'apprécie sur le
plan personnel n'est pas le dernier à
activer aussi beaucoup d'éléments de
division depuis 12 mois d'accord et y
compris bon je vais arrêter de critiquer
les uns et les autres parce que le
principal c'est que nous trouvions
les conditions du rassemblement sur le
programme le programme de laanupes il
est là ne le remettons pas en cause on
peut discuter comment on hiérarchisee
tel ou tel sujet mais il nous a
rassemblé c'est un programme de rupture
on va dire avec actuellement l'ordre
économique le désordre écologique et qui
nous propose des solution démocratique
pour passer en 6e république qui est
quand même le sujet la grande
conversation qui est qu'un sentiment
général d'une 5e République qui met à
distance le peuple ça c'est passionnant
on a déjà une base qui nous a rassemblé
il y a un an ça semblait impossible
aujourd'hui il y a des tensions dontcte
la question c'est comment on se réunit
me moi c'est comme ça que j'aiie de
prendre le problème de dire aux uns et
aux autres comment est encore possible
avec jeanl je me battrai jusqu'au bout
pour qu'elle le soit pour qu'elle soit
possible sinon je ne serai pas à la
hauteur de la tâche parce que la
division c'est les clés qui sont données
soit un éventuel successeur de Monsieur
Macron pour continuer la même politique
et l'impression que j'ai c'est que les
frçce qu' là cherche pas un peu la
division en faisant ça je et bien moi je
suis infatigable sur le fait qu'il faut
arriver à l'Union est-ce que vous ê
est-ce que vous êtes intimement
convaincu vous qui connaissez bien que
il souhait être
remplacé moi je prends les gens au mot
je fais pas de possain d' inention on
donne mandant en disant qu'il souhait
être remplacé je m'y emploie et je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait des gens qui
avancent dans cette voie c'est ce qui a
été demandé par Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
ce qui demandé par beaucoup de gens il
faudra que nous ayons une candidate ou
un candidat qui porte nos couleurs me
semble-t-il du rassemblement la
prochaine fois pour cette fois-ci non
pas faire un bon score ce sera ma
conclusion la seule tâche qui nous est
donnée aujourd'hui c'est de créer les
conditions d'être au second
et de l'emporter au second tour moi je
vais essayer de mettre service petite
expérience pour aider à ce processus là
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité merci Fabrice à la semaine
prochaine club territo